is there a way to find your true passion
where is that just a cliche
what's definitely its Lachey and it you
know it it's the sort of thing that
actually annoys me quite a lot about New
Age thinkers and I would more or less
put Joseph Campbell in that category I
think you can find what compels you and
what might enable you to live in a high
quality manner despite the suffering
that's associated with life I think you
can discover that and I think part of
the way you discover that is by watching
yourself and learning when it is that
you're meaningfully engaged you have to
notice that it's something that happens
to you in some sense rather than
something that you do you have to notice
when you're meaningfully engaged and
then you have to work to expand the
amount of time that you spend in that
state but I would also say that there
are moral requirements that go along
with that too because you might say well
what if you happen to be this sort of
person for example who finds torturing
small animals meaningfully engaging it
seems like that's a that's the sort of
meaningful engagement that you probably
don't want to expand so I would say that
if you're going to set up your life so
that you maximize your meaningful
engagement you have to there's a number
of other things that you have to do at
the same time and one of those is that
you have to get very clear about who you
are and what you're doing and so
although this would be grounds for a
much longer discussion I think that one
of the things that you have to do if
you're going to attempt to maximize
meaningful engagement is that you also
have to do such things as endeavor to
stop deceiving yourself and other people
in every way you possibly can and part
of the reason for that is that if you
engage in deception of any sort you
pathologize the structure first the
structure of your being but you could
say you pathologies the structure
your nervous system and then you can't
trust its reports so if your nerd if
you're going to rely on your nervous
systems reports of meaningful engagement
to guide your future activities you
better do everything you can to make
sure that you're not filling that
nervous system with the kind of garbage
that's going to make it malfunction and
give again give you false reports so I
think that moving towards meaningful
engagement has to be associated with
making truth your highest value because
otherwise you can't trust yourself as
your own guide I mean the Catholics have
struggled with this for a long time from
a theological perspective because the
Catholic position roughly speaking is
that human beings are so steeped in sin
that they can't trust their own
instincts in relationship to good and
evil and have to use the church and the
priesthood as an intermediary and you
know you can obviously have an argument
about that and of course Protestants
have historically done that but you got
to give the Catholics their do it's like
people aren't pure by nature and only
trammeled in their vision by you know
sociological impediments they're also
corrupt beyond belief individually and
have to use society as a source of value
so if you're going to personalize your
life in some sense you better act in a
manner that makes you a reliable guide